[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute but let's do it in a way that
makes the snowflakes heads explode let
me be clear before this podcast begins
we are loud proud proud and do not give
a
[Music]
[__] this is the Tony Michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people is not Liberty
you [__] eating [__] ah the smell of
freedom of speech this is the Tony
Michaels podcast and this is Tony
Michaels hey Tony [__]
[Music]
them
$119,000 for a Podium have you heard
this [__] I just found out that Sarah
Huckabee Sanders sold sto toal
$112,000 of the state of Arkansas's
money apparently she's blaming it on a
Podium what the [__] how did I miss this
how in the hell did I miss this how did
I miss this oh man there's a lot of
disarray in the world today isn't there
holy [__] you talk about piles and piles
of news there's a lot of it because
there's a lot of information out there
and there's a lot of misinformation out
there be careful folks what you believe
and what you read
holy actual [__] the lead story today is
that uh Republicans in the house are
meeting in a secret in a secret
conference so that they so that the
public doesn't know that Trump is
handpicking the speaker of the house
that's
why that's why all the media is trying
to figure out who are meeting in secret
what's the who's gon to be the speaker
BL blah whoever Trump picks is going to
be the speaker this is how
authoritarianism works I've been telling
you this time and time and time again
people are really pissed off at me today
about a tweet that I uh put out and they
say I should delete it [__] that I'm not
deleting [__] I stand by my tweet and
and if you don't do your job and
participate and engage in democracy it
will come to life I'm gonna show you
more videos
today of a mar maral candidate in
Franklin Tennessee standing by literal
Nazis she's a republ
Conservative candidate who is after the
lgbtq
community she's a
Nazi because I mean again if there's a
Nazi at a table and 10 other people are
having dinner with that Nazi yucking up
telling jokes having a great
time there's 11 Nazis at that table
that's how it works and people are mad
this morning that I tweeted that MAA is
the America's
Hamas I mean they're like oh Tony you
need to delete this tweet they haven't
they haven't murdered 1,200 people have
you been listening to what [__] Trump
has been saying have you been listening
to what Dan santis has been saying
they're talking about executing people
in [__] retail stores because they're
shoplifting they're talking about
executing brown people at the border no
due process of
law you need to Puck your head out of
your [__] ass if you think I'm if I'm
being hyperbolic calling manga America's
Hamas are you kidding me [__] out of
here with this
nonsense they can't even govern and
honestly this morning this conference um
uh George Santos is charged with I think
23 new felonies including identity theft
and credit card fraud something like
that we'll go through that today but
also his doppelganger showed up with a
goddamn rope to Lynch somebody I guess I
don't know what the [__] she Harriet hag
man this this Hag from Wyoming the one
that replaced Liz Cheney you know what I
mean this Mite that replac Liz Cheney
shows up with a a [__]
rope and I'm the one that's speaking
speaking at a turn here by calling MAA
America's Hamas well you can be mad at
me all you want that's fine I don't be
mad be mad that's what you should be is
you should be pissed off of what is
happening in this
country they can't even govern and then
we have the the the governor of Arkansas
stealing again another member of MAA one
of the original members of Maga one of
the original Maga
Liars Sarah hakabe Sanders smokey eye
stealing
$112,000 of the state's money I mean
really it's $1 19,000 because she spent
$7,000 on the on the
[__] on the the podium this because
she got caught see smells like
embezzlement to
me I think she's in big [__] she's in
George Santos type trouble down in
Arkansas if you want to know the honest
truth feels like it to me it's not
surprising though it's not
surprising Donald Trump calling for more
violence in this country not not
overseas in this
country and I'm out of turn Republican
Republican candidates for mayor and
Tennessee are ping around with Nazis
they're threatening they're threatening
voters lives in Tennessee because
they're
questioning the candidates values
whether she's a Nazi or not and the
Alderman's I'm going to show you this
video and I know I get stuck on this
story but I believe that this this is
the story that you need to be paying
attention to
folks it is dangerous to have a a a
candidate for president of the United
States who has 91 felony charges and
four different jurisdictions he's out on
bail in those four
jurisdictions there are going to be
literally thousands of people thousands
of people go to jail and prison because
they believe that Donald Trump was sent
here by
God and they went to try to overthrow
our government and committed crimes in
his
name because of
God right they're God are you following
me they hail him as their
leader and I'm speaking out of turn when
I call Maga America's Hamas they can't
even pick a speaker of the house without
Donald Trump anointing them I still
believe Jim Jordan's is I don't know how
long it's going to take but Jim Jordan's
getting immersed merge as the speaker of
the house that's my belief because
Donald Trump has anointed him has
endorsed him unless Donald Trump moves
his endorsement because that's what's
happening inside the Republican Party
authoritarianism that's the reason why
they can't
govern is because they're
authoritarian they don't have a choice
but to genuflect to their dear leader
they don't have a choice to do his
bidding and to do that [__] radicals
bidding that's why they can't that's why
they can't get leadership that's why
they can't compromise it's the reason
why they demonize our fellow
countrymen basically calling them
monsters trying to eradicate them in in
in states by passing laws to get rid of
the lgbtq community and then we have
Mayors are candidates for mayor but
she's an alderman she's a sitting
Alderman she's elected official in
Tennessee and folks if you think this is
just in this town in Tennessee you're
you're [__] out of your
mind there is an Insurgency in our
country it is real it is here and it is
it is out there and they are not scared
to tell you who the [__] they
are and the reason why the House of
Representatives can't get the Republican
caucus to pick a speaker is because
Donald TR they have to plate to Donald
Trump
they're
Hitler doubt me on this just do it
whatever you want to do you can act like
Al Tony that's a disgusting tweet
comparing comparing a bunch of Nazis to
Hamas
what you think that's the wrong
comparison well I'm here to tell you I'm
here to tell you that we just not need
to be vigilant around the world but in
our country here these people are
spreading
lies lies after lies after
lies the Texas the Texas Republicans
apparently met with Nick
Fuentes Nick Fuentes saying that oh
that's all set
up the terrorist attacks on Israel from
Hamas that was all [__] [__] it's
all it's all a false flag so that
Israel can can kill
Arab
fascist and it's all a call to more
violence towards Jewish
people and the Texas Republicans are
meeting with this
Nazi you think the American Nazis are on
the side of Israel
here I mean the Republican party is
doing everything they can do to pretend
that they love
Israel I mean the only reason why the
party the party still is with Israel
anyways is because exactly what Donald
Trump said months ago he warned Jewish
people you better get back to Israel
American Jews you better get back to
Israel you better do that you better get
back there I have someone that left the
comment this morning on a vinmo chat and
it's true it's the goddamn
truth this is a complex issue these
things are not easy to deal
with
they're not easy to understand
right because most of this division is
division of some kind of spaghetti
monster in the [__] Sky my God's
better than your God my God has a bigger
dick than your
God it's
religion and religion breeds brutal
Bloody Disgusting war is what it
breeds and I hope people of Faith out
there understand
that that your faith is different from
religion and your personal independent
belief is different than
religion because we're not going to fix
these issues tomorrow that's how complex
it
is but as we're thinking about what's
going on around the world and what's
going on in our
country we better start making the we
better start making better decisions in
our
democracy and not just the decision at
the ballot I mean that's one of the most
important decisions that we have to
make thank thank thank the spaghetti
monster in the sky whichever one you
pray to if you pray to
one that we decided to get our asses out
in 2020 and put someone in power that
has a level [__] head
seeing what's happening this week in the
world some Republicans are saying this
is all it's all Biden's fault hell some
of the crazy right-wing are saying this
is all Obama I'm not [__] you I'm
not [__] kidding you I wouldn't [__]
you you're my favorite turd there some
of them are blaming it on
Obama crazy ass
[__]
some are spinning conspiracy theories
that somehow the the Intel that Trump
gave lavro in the Oval Office years
ago is the reason why Hamas was able to
break the Iron
Dome the misinformation is everywhere
everywhere and it's intended to be that
way
that's their goal that's their
mission MAA that's their mission in this
country is to divide
us is to confuse
us but we not we must not keep our eye
off the ball no matter what is happening
around the
world no matter what the narrative is
and we can stand against
terrorism and we can be humanitarians
all at the same time that is a thing
what we can
do you can believe that we that that
that Palestinians have
Humanity that we should act
Humane and still know that Hamas is a
group of terrorists and if we do not do
something us as the American people
support Israel that they will murder
more innocent
people and you can believe folks you can
believe that God's the city is an open
air City and there are atrocities that
happen
there and in those atrocities Israel is
not is not [__]
innocent all these things can be true
all of them all at the same [__]
time and you don't have to both sides
the [__]
either someone else pointing out this
morning my comments that MAA is the
America's h
is that Iran is to Hamas what Russia is
to Maga it's just funny how Russia
supports Iran and magas loves Putin it's
kind of funny isn't
it kind of makes you think kind of makes
you think that the chaos is
intended that it's intentional
chaos oh but I'm out of hand for
pointing it
out how dare I
if you think that I'm not going to point
out what I see to be happening in our
country in our country our [__]
country this country the United States
of America if you think I'm not going to
point that [__] out you're out of your
mind I'm gonna point it out every
goddamn
time and it does not matter who gets mad
at
me who gets upset at me most of the time
it is going to be MAA I'm not going to
lie to you it's going to be them a
lot because they are domestic terrorists
they are an Insurgency in our country
now not every single person who believes
in MAA is is the domestic terrorist
themselves but they definitely support
them even if they don't know what they
are because Maga might not see
themselves as American Nazis but the
American Nazis think they're
Nazis and that's the
threat
I'm telling you I'm going to give you
I'm going to show you again today in
Tennessee in a little town called
Franklin there are Nazis threatening
people's lives because they are pointing
out that one of the candidates for mayor
she is Ping around with Nazis and those
Nazis are
threatening those voters the olderman
there are standing staunchly against the
sitting Alderman Hansen who is running
for
mayor again it's like oh well that's
just one little town
Tony that's just one little
town how do you think that [__]
starts how do you think it starts
huh how do you think these types of
atrocities around the world start where
do you think they start
hate and wanting to eradicate your
fellow humans stripping them of all
Humanity that's where it [__]
starts and it won't in there if we don't
stop them and it is very important in
this country that we stand on our
Democratic
principles to make sure that everyone
all people every [__] is
afforded the same rights and Liberty the
same Equity the same equality that we
embrace our diversity
and stand on the foundation of Liberty
that is liberal democracy here in this
country I don't give a [__] if you don't
think it's a democracy if you if you are
diluted and you believe that it's only a
Democrat or only excuse me only a
constitutional republic it is a
democracy and there is no better example
right now in this country of the
threat against what is going to happen
if we don't stand together as a
pro-democracy
coalition and use our ballots to fight
back then this race this mayor race in
Franklin Tennessee and it sounds crazy
but it's
true the Nazis running around ping
around with
Hansen in
Tennessee the [__] has a proud
boy tattoo on his face the same
[__] that went to our
Capital who tried to overthrow our
government take away our vote to Crown
Donald Trump the dictator and King of
the United States of stupidity in their
eyes same [__] he's got it
tattooed on his
face
some of the proud booy leaders are
sitting in prison right now for that
coup
attempt
folks I'm not speaking out of
turn I'm just telling you if we don't
get
together because we outnumber them oh
God do we outnumber
them don't believe that those [__]
polls that the media's trying to [__]
feed
you the fear porn that they're trying to
feed you to get you
scared that we aren't the majority in
this country because we
are and it's going to be a long hard
slog here it's going to be a hell of a
battle between now and next
November because these Republican Nazi
criminals are out and about
and they're trying to take power
wherever they can and they're trying to
remain in power wherever they
can and my advice to any Republican out
there who is sick and tired of being
called what I call them American Nazis
my my suggestion is is you drop the
r maybe do what RFK Jr did I don't know
being an independent [__] why not
hell at least some people won't question
if you're with the American Nazis
and I know it's confusing I know it's
confusing because you you go online and
you see that you're you agree with like
Ben Shapiro right you're like wow that's
[__] weird it sucks
right but don't lose the
focus don't lose focus
because if we don't keep our eye on the
ball in this country what has happened
around the world can happen here the
Insurgency is [__]
real it's real folks and they oh man
they desperately they desperately the
leaders of the Insurgency Trump himself
desperately want these people to be
violent so much so that they're I mean
even Dan santis who who wants to be the
leader he won't be but he wants to be
he's out of money he's out of
time he wants to be the leader
bad you're calling to execute people
with due process of law just execute
them just shoot them kill them what does
that sound like to
you does that sound like the
Constitution of the United States of
America does that sound like Law and
Order to you what does that sound like
to you these are the people who want to
be [__] president of the United
States
dummy it's not hard to understand these
things they're they're two steps
away from publicly calling to execute
the lgbtq community just two steps
they're not too far away from it [__]
they're taking away Women's Healthcare
even when their lives are on the line
they want to get him out of the military
Tommy tuberville or should I call him
tumber
tumble Ville you see him he fell down
the [__] steps oh I'm going to show
that video it's hilarious couldn't
happened to a better guy
honestly they want women out of the
military but I'm the one who's out of my
out of my mind and I should be deleting
tweets good luck with that
[__] good
luck I'm not going to stop yelling and
screaming I'm not going to stop pointing
it out to you of what is on the horizon
if we don't dig our heels in and use
democracy to save the son of a
[__] and honestly sunlight is the best
disinfectant yes it is I'm here to tell
you sunlight is the best disinfectant
and my YouTube shorts I tell you what
they're getting into the bubble of
maanga they're hearing my [__]
voice
and that's the key to
this that's the key to this not only
having our own narrative and pushing our
own
narrative making sure they know we're
here and that there's someone that is
willing to punch that
bag and we're not just going to be just
go quietly into the
night why they take over our country
take over Franklin Tennessee demonize
LGBT Q people because that's where it
starts in one town in one
Community that's where it [__] starts
and it will balloon out if we don't do
something in this country and what you
need to do is engage in your democracy
and protect people's rights and their
freedom it's about
Liberty I believe in the right for Nazis
to go and support Ronda santz on an
overpass in Florida that's right I
support that right honestly I hope they
keep doing it because it exposed Ronda
santz for who the [__] he is just like I
hope those Nazis keep protecting Hansen
in Franklin Tennessee because it exposes
her for who she truly is sunlight is
truly the best
disinfectant once the truth is known we
can move the [__]
on Jesus Christ's project 2025 stuff
wait till we start diving into this
thing and you're really going to find
out what their motives are what their
plan is for you and your community and
your
family and you then then then you can
come to me and you can tell me you can
tell me that Hamas isn't Nazis and Nazis
aren't Hamas and Maga aren't Nazis then
you can come tell me then you can come
tell me to delete
tweets and until then I will not and I
will not back down and I will
not I will not act like and normalize
Maga in this
country it is an Insurgency into our
political
body and if our society normalizes
it yes it will stay around and it will
hang around our necks for
Generations
but we must move on in our democracy we
must move to a better place we must
progress to
inclusion diversity and equity for all
[__] people here in our border I
don't give a [__] who they
are but your individualism does not you
do not have the right to oppress my
individualism with
yours the freedom to oppress the rights
of other people is not
Liberty you [__] eating
[__] period And if you think it is
well then we have a big disagreement
don't go anywhere we'll be right back
right after
this what the [__] is wrong with you
people it's a rhetorical question at
[Music]
best we'll be right back on the Tony
Michaels
[Music]
podcast fellow Patriots what would you
do if there was a trump supporter right
in front of you crying in pain because
they have to live under communist
tyranny we know what you would do you'd
reach out and give that true American a
hand now here's your chance for only $50
a day you can help us help those true
Americans recover from Biden socialist
reign of terror these are those Trump
supporters and this is that moment send
your donation via venmo to the real
president Donald J Trump it's only $50 a
day recurring and it means you'll get
these Trump supporters the critical help
they so desperately need to survive
under this false regime please donate
now because those Trump supporters you
just saw can't wait another
moment [__] them [__] [__] them [__]
[__] them [__] we're back to the Tony
Michaels
[Music]
podcast oh
boy you know that we're not going to
agree all the time and this is a large
audience and it's going to get bigger
and bigger and bigger every single day
every month every year it's just going
to get more and more and there's going
to be more people and we're going to
have more disagreements and we're not
going to agree on every single little
point right you know that right like
that's actually how democracy works
that's the beauty that's the beauty of
democracy is we don't have to agree on
every [__] thing we don't just like
we don't have to agree with the Nazis
standing on the overpass in Florida
supporting Ronda santz we do not have to
agree with Gabriel Hansen the Nazi in
Tennessee trying to become the mayor of
Franklin but I mean I'm not calling for
the
eradication of Nazis I'm just saying
what we should do is have better [__]
ideas and we should we should fill our
government coffers for a people with
better
ideas that believe in the people that
have [__]
Humanity oh man oh boy controversial
there just because I do it with a little
bit of
punch and a little bit of
pizzazz doesn't mean
[__] I mean some people in the comments
are like but BB Netanyahu is a right-
Winger yeah he is that is true he's a
right winger and he's tried to March the
Israeli government closer to the right
wing does does that does that mean that
Hamas isn't a bunch of [__]
terrorists no no it does not does not
mean
that two things can be true at the same
time even though they don't
compute with the same world viiew and
I'm telling you I'm telling you I'm
telling you if if you're if you're
making
very very very pointed
statements that you better be willing to
[__] defend them
okay that's what I do every [__] day
is come here and defend
democracy now it's it's through the lens
of My Views certainly I mean it's my
commentary I'm trying to be authentic
I'm trying to show you exactly what I
feel and how I feel and yes I'm taking a
stance
it doesn't mean that you shouldn't
either listen good ideas will prevail
over bad ones every single
time every single time good ideas it
takes a while sometimes it takes a
while it does it's not always it's not
always you know Perfect Right democracy
is not perfect again that's kind of the
idea we're gonna make mistakes we're
gonna have flaws our history is [__]
mired in
flaws and to try to pretend to ignore
them and to ignore our history and to
ignore the facts because it makes oh it
might make white people feel guilty well
tough [__] [__] if you're guilty
you're the one that needs to hear
it you're the one that needs to hear
it and I know the audience here the
majority of the audience right now in
this
moment agrees with me on most
points and believes in
democracy hell just the simple fact that
we are a
democracy but it ain't going to remain
that way
forever we're going to have a lot of
[__] hate Watchers a lot of [__]
hate listeners
here as we continue to do this people
are going to hate my [__]
guts and I'm just warning you the people
out there love me that's probably why
you love me mainly is because there's
plenty of people who love to hate me and
those [__] are the exact people
that we should have loved to hating
us but know this know this I will defend
what I say I will defend what I
believe I will [__] defend
it and the only reason why I am on the
the internet yelling and screaming into
a
microphone in my defense of my position
of democracy is so that you seek
inspiration of the
same it's it it's a cathartic
release yes is there underlying tones
for a national narrative to promote
democracy you goddamn right I want my
children my grandchildren your children
your grandchildren your
great-grandchildren
to live in a country where they have
Liberty as much Liberty that is possible
and moving towards more Liberty every
single day that we can get is it perfect
[__] no no it's not perfect it never
will be
perfect and if you're looking for a
perfect democracy where you're looking
for something that doesn't exist and you
again you're in the wrong you're in the
wrong
mission
so I will stand by my position and if I
listen if I if I figure out that I'm
wrong I will tell you
that I've changed many of my positions
throughout the years many of my
positions it's one reason why I have
such conviction on some of these
issues one being Liberty for all [__]
people I don't care who the [__] you are
what religion you are what race you are
what what your sexual orientation is I
don't give a [__] I don't care what your
name
is I don't care if you're a citizen of
this country or not a citizen of this
country I believe in [__]
Liberty did I always no I was raised in
rural Missouri in a white
Community diluted by white
privilege I'll tell you a story story
that kind of changed my mind about the
lgbtq community I was very young I was
in my early 20s I went to Chicago to
visit a friend in college I went to a
party at that party there was two gay
men and I [__] you not I got
uncomfortable because one of them was
sitting on the other one's lap that's
why I got uncomfortable I didn't make a
huge scene but everyone knew why I was
leaving and thinking back on that moment
I realized I realized how ridiculous I
was
being I realized how my thinking was not
straight it was not inclusive it was
ridiculous that I expect someone else to
Give me liberty but I won't give them
theirs it changed my mind because I used
my [__] brain
and I thought about it and I realized
that my true conviction if I'm going to
hold that true conviction for myself I
must hold it for others it totally
changed my
worldview on all sorts of
issues my one mistake it's embarrassing
one of the most embarrassing things I've
probably ever done in my
life I regret that moment more
than me going to federal prison that's
right I regret that moment more but you
know what I hold that
moment in high
regard and the reason why is because I
was able to [__]
think I was able to use my brain
cells I was able to understand why I
believe what I believe and that I should
extend that belief to
others it's not [__]
complicated
it's not [__]
complicated it's not hard to
understand and I am not going to cast
out my countrymen because of who they
love because of what they want to be or
who or what gender they want to call
themselves the [__] is wrong with
you I'm not going to cast them out
why because he was sitting on another
another man's
lap because I got scared because I was
uncomfortable
no I decided that I would change my
view I've been wrong before I'll be
wrong
again but this is why I tell you what I
tell you why I tell you how I tell
you it's because of moments like
that do I believe that we will be able
to to to change the
minds of all manga cult members no we're
not going to change the minds of all
manga cult members and if you want to
know the honest truth most people aren't
actually manga cult
members the ones who are going to vote
for Trump anyways most of its
Association vote in the first place
honestly this RFK Jr thing is
frightening the cult and the reason why
it's frightening the cult is because
they see him as the as the easy out for
people who who are ashamed that it's a
[__] cult and somehow they're still
[__] voting with these [__] morons
this band of idiots who tried to
overthrow our
vote
we can do this I'm telling you and I
know it seems uh a heavy strain right
now when you when we have what we have
going
on in Israel and overseas and in Ukraine
I know it feels like it's a
strain and it's
tough and it's easy just to stick your
fingers in your ears and your hands over
your
eyes to just ignore it and it'll all go
away well it's not going to go
away just like my bigotry in that moment
when I was younger at that party my
bigotry wasn't just going to go away I
had to change
it I had to do
something and I thought through the
process and I changed my mind and yeah
yeah again am I was I totally ashamed
afterwards and in the Years leading up
to this I've been totally ashamed of
it and it's embarrassing to even tell
the
story but it's important that you
know because I know you have stories
just like
mine I know you have stories just like
mine and it may not be the exact same
one it may that not be the exact same
change that I made in my belief and my
thinking because really it wasn't a far
stretch from my belief I I believe that
all people because I want individual
liberty and if I want it why can't I
extend it to other
people and me getting all been out of
shape and uncomfortable in a house party
because some some dude sitting on
another dude's
lap what does that mean for my
Liberty huh
so we're all in this
together and it's perfectly fine for us
to be wrong it's perfectly fine for us
to be wrong until we're right and it's
perfectly fine for us to be right until
we're
wrong I'm telling
you do not back down from the defense of
your
beliefs especially if your de beliefs
are in this in the foundation of liberal
democracy because liberalism is not
weakness when you when you extend the
opportunity for for everyone to be who
they are and you extend the opportunity
for everyone to make the choices that
you are
afforded that is not
weakness it is
not speaking of
weakness oh my god oh Republicans in the
house they're such [__] boxes aren't
they oh my God honestly I hope they keep
going I you know what everyone's like oh
man this is this is bad for the
institution of the House of
Representatives well of course it is
yeah it is sure it's [__] horrible
for the institution of the House of
Representatives that the Republican
Party have control over it but how how
the [__] else are we going to
show America how they can't [__]
govern if we don't show them and just
let them do it that's why the Democrats
voted to vacate Kevin McCarthy because
they're not going to vote for a [__]
Republican speaker of the house
especially someone who capitulates to
Donald Trump [__] out of here with that
nonsense watch this [__] it's a what's
her name is it Hagerman or hag is it
just hag um it's it's Jordan Santos's
doppelganger I swear to God I has anyone
seen these two people in the same room
I'm just wondering there's George Santos
news too we're gonna get to that
hopefully Jesus Christ there's so much
[__] news right now even about this
Podium that uh Sarah Huckaby Sanders is
trying to embezzle money with have you
heard this thing I didn't hear this till
yesterday I was like what the [__] are
you kidding me this story's been going
on for weeks and I didn't even pay
attention to it I'm like son of a [__]
why the hell wasn't I on top of that but
here we go
here's look what she has in her hand
when she's walking through
here and is she carrying a [__] rope
she's got a [__] rope
now George here that's I I'm telling you
I don't know if I don't know if they've
ever been seen the same room I'm not
really sure so if we get rid of George
Santos in Congress which Republicans
this morning are calling for George
Santos to leave Congress more
Republicans are calling for George
Santos to leave Congress maybe they'll
lose two seats here the one in Wyoming
and then the one in New
York that's a lasso yes people are
asking is that Al
lasso RJ W says is that a lasso in her
yep that's a [__] lasso she's got a
rope now I don't know if you know this
but when there is a when there is a
house Speaker vote the Democrats are
going to nominate Hakeem Jeff and every
[__] Democrat is going to vote for
AEM Jeff that is going to be a thing
because the Democrats aren't in
disarray and and they're they're they're
together on this they're together on
governing and they're together on one
point democracy like they all agree on
that and they're they're banding a
coalition of Democrats and the Democrat
Caucus around that one idea democracy
and they're not straying away from it
the the Republicans are the ones that
are and have been in disarray they just
been lying to us to say that they're not
but here she is with a [__] lasso
look at that here
she there's more evidence right there
there's last there oh there it is there
see H you can kind of see it right there
see right there right there there's the
lasto she's got a
rope what do you think she's gonna hang
with the Rope huh I don't know I don't
know maybe she's trying to say she's a
cowboy cowboy remember the the you
remember the the the [__] Kid Rock
song cowboy Oh my
God that that was like only that was one
of like three hits he had I wonder if he
still sings that song because he thinks
it's cool or something I don't know uh
my friend Jeremy London uh made a good
good point the point that I just made
Jeremy pointed out here a black man is
being voted on for speaker today she
brought a lynching rope what the [__]
that's kind of weird not gonna lie that
is kind of weird
kind of [__] weird that you would
bring a rope to a speaker
vote now Republicans are having this
meeting behind closed doors uh what
they're doing is they're trying to
figure out because what they don't want
to do what Republicans don't want to do
is go out to the house floor for a
speaker vote and it take 15 more [__]
times and then they still end up with
Kevin McCarthy are you following me
that's that's right that's that's what
they don't want they don't want to have
the same thing happen in January because
what it what it
proves which is what we need to prove to
America by just watching them right just
let them do their stupid [__] and watch
them and point it out like look at these
[__] idiots they're bringing in ropes
to vote for house Speaker talk about
jumping the [__]
shark here's the
thing is that they don't want to have
15 more [__] votes on the house floor
and end up with Kevin McCarthy as a
speaker again now the choices that you
have Jesus right now are Jim Jord Jim I
don't report sex crimes Jordan
which because he's because he's
elevating to the speaker of the house
and it it feels that way folks honestly
I'm not I I think Jim Jordan's gonna be
the speaker of the house here unless
Trump changes his endorsement if you
believe that anyone but who Trump
endorses is going to be the speaker of
the house you're outside your [__]
mind you're not understanding how the
Republican party is operating why they
have this why they have the in
incapability of governing in the first
place they don't have the ability to
govern because Donald Trump is
controlling them with
authoritarianism that's why that's
why
uh so he's gonna pick the speaker of the
house because he truly is the speaker of
the house because he believes that he
needs to shut down government to stop
all the whatever he thinks is going to
happen to him which it's all [__]
crashing down upon Him Donald Trump that
is all this stuff is g to catch him soon
just like just like the
$199,000 that it appears that the
governor Sarah Huckabee Smokey ey
Sanders stole from the um embezzled is
what it appears to be oh boy it appears
she embezzled 19 did you hear what I
just said I know I it's crazy I can't
believe the story Sarah hakabe Sanders
you know that the Arkansas governor
Arkansas Republicans [__] hate her
guts you know that they see her as a
carpet
bagger because she hadn't lived in
Arkansas forever she lived in Washington
DC she's a Trumper the only reason why
she won the governorship is because
Trump endorser H I wonder why Tony's
saying the person that the that the
house and Trump endorses in the house is
going to be the speaker huh wonder what
the [__] it
is I wonder what evidence like at point
to Dr Oz he became the candidate for the
Republican Party herel Walker became the
candidate of the Republican Party JD
Vance even though Trump didn't know his
name he became the [__] candidate for
the Republican
party I I don't know what more evidence
I need to point out to you I mean I can
keep going if you want me to Sarah
Huckabee Sanders is the governor of
Arkansas again the Republican party in
Arkansas hates that [__] [__] and for
good reason apparently because she's
trying to embezzle $199,000 from the
state of Arkansas it looks like she's
doctoring invoices I know I'm kind of
off topic here but I'm trying to show
you why I believe that that [__] Jim
Jordan may be the Speaker of the House
small Rance points out a good point here
it's not JD Vance it's JP Mandel you're
right you're right I'm wrong that's
literally what Trump called JD Vance was
JP Mandel when he endorsed him on stage
in front of a [__] crowd of tens of
people and JD Vance went on to win the
nomination and the senate seat and Trump
didn't even know his [__] name but
because he endorsed him he became the
nominee it's [__] wild
[__] wild [__]
[__] but this is the proof that I offer
you not because I'm trying to prove
people wrong because I'm I'm trying to
show you what's going to
happen uh oh boy do you think George
Santos who is he gonna vote
for this guy gets a vote I I want to
show you a
video yeah we're just gonna jump into
George Santos [__] it we just keep going
here we got a lot of [__] to cover today
here's George Santos trying to run away
from reporters after he was indicted uh
a superseding indictment boy these
Republican criminals really have a lot
of superseding indictments don't they oh
and there's plenty more to come plenty
more superseding indictments to come
apparently George Santos alleged in this
indictment was
using [__] his campaign or his his
donors for his campaign's credit card
information I don't know what he was
buying I don't know if he was buying
like drag costumes or what but let's
find out if George Santos know that he's
got a superseding indictment here oh
comment I was I did not have access to
my
phone of the
amican oh no clue no they said he stole
people idti I love how he's pretending
to be on his phone don't you like he's
like yeah like he's on the phone with
his [__] lawyer he's like what
they're indicting me on what oh yeah I
did that yeah I totally did that oh
that's illegal oh I didn't think that
was illegal I didn't think that was
illegal this [__] guy watch this [__]
this is great people's identities
uhuh no comment I was in conf you have
comment you can't defend what you did
you piece of [__] no one can defend what
the [__] you did the craziest part of
all the craziest part of all is that
he's gonna vote for speaker and they
need his vote to get to 217 they need
this son [__] they need this [__]
criminal to vote in their criminal
[__]
speaker how do you why do you think this
works like
this and you think I'm at a turn to
point out that
MAA is a bunch of [__]
terrorist they're using criminals
they're using [__] criminals who
defrauded his [__] donors he took his
Don this is what they're alleging he and
and it seems that way because The
Treasure of his campaign already pled
guilty to [__]
charges turned on
him flipped State evidence so she
doesn't have to go to [__] prison as
long as George Santos does I don't know
if you know this but this mother
fucker's bound to catch seven to 12
years in a federal [__] prison over
this
[__] that's right hold me to it someone
mark it down doubt me October 11th
Wednesday 1254 Tony said George Santos
is gonna get seven to 12
years that's if he goes to trial if he
doesn't go to trial if he pleads guilty
which he probably will because 99% of
federal cases end up in plea deals in
the first place he'll he'll probably cop
about three to four years so mark that
[__] down otherwise you'll get seven to
12 oh couldn't happen to a better
[__] let me be honest with you
my phone so I
have
sir did you charge to your credit card
owners money you use their credit cards
to reward yourself that's the allegation
I I at
it why should you be able to vote in the
speaker's election such a key election
when you've been charged with all these
crimes he's just a typical average
Republican he really truly is do you
remember at the beginning of the year I
told you that I did not want George
Santos to resign that I thought that the
Republican should stand behind that son
of a [__] just because they need him
they need his vote to [__] do their
Donald Trump manga
domestic terrorist bidding in the house
they're authoritarian bidding in the
house I told you I told you way back
when I did not want him to resign that
it would be a tool for us to show the
world who the Republicans are
boom
boom now it's correct and I'll continue
to be correct because the Republicans
are not going to ask this [__]
they're not going to get rid of him I
mean there's some Republicans out there
asking him to resign I'm not I'm not
going to shake that there are some
Republicans because they know how bad
this looks let me see if I can find the
the clip here of these Republicans here
here they are here it is the other New
York Republicans this is this is
representative uh uh Loda Nick Nick and
Anthony now here I I'll just show this
to you you can see this here here's a
couple Representatives talking about
George santz he does not I think there
are two separate requirements two
separate standards what he is um known
to be guilty of uh with Beyond any doubt
not just the Reasonable Doubt is that he
lied about his entire background that to
me and how he defrauded voters Long
Island voters um should disqualify him
from holding this office well you know
what I I want to make sure that all
these Republican Representatives come
out and they they condemn and they ask
the one of the presidential candidates
for the Republican party for the biggest
financial credit card fraud in American
history did you know that did you know
in 2020 Donald Trump in his campaign
committed the largest
largest credit card fraud scheme in
American
history did you know that yeah that's
right that's a real [__] thing when
are these Republicans gonna gonna come
out and condemn that when are they going
to come out and say that Donald Trump
should should be in should be in prison
for it huh when when are you gonna do
that they're not gonna do it just as
disingenuous as this [__] is because
they send two people out to condemn him
and to condemn his lies what the [__]
are you talking about man you know you
know it's it's August 11th
2023 we knew about George Santos's lies
in January this year where the [__] have
they been huh where the [__] have they
been oh they hid behind his vote because
they needed
it because Republicans don't have any
[__] principle at
all they
don't they don't have any principle at
all that's why they can't condemn even
what Bob Mendez a Democratic senator
from New Jersey did they can't even come
out and condemn that and the reason why
they can't they can't ask Bob Menendez
which I I think that [__] should
resign he should give the opportunity to
for new jerseyans to get [__]
represented as someone other than a
goddamn
criminal he should have enough [__]
cth about him to do that but he doesn't
because he's a criminal Bob Mendez is a
piece of [__] that's right Bob as a
Democratic senator is 100% a piece of
[__] trash just like George Santos
just like Donald
Trump when the [__] when the [__] is the
Republican Party gonna come out and ask
Bob Menendez to resign huh they won't
they can't because if they say that Bob
Menendez can't be in the Senate and
George Santos can't be in the Congress
then they have to admit that Donald
Trump shouldn't be the president of the
United States
so they can't they can't go against the
dear leader they can't go against the
dear leader just like they can't go
against the dear
leaders nomination of Jim Jordan in the
house it's not complicated to know these
things it's [__] right out there in
the open H are saying it right out
loud I mean Jesus Christ the Republican
Party won't even get Tommy tuber villain
order speaking of the Senate they won't
even get him in [__]
order so to make sure that we get the
actual promotions in at DOD that we need
to be ready and to be effective
especially seeing that we have what we
have going on around the
world but I got a video to show you of
Tommy
tuberville couldn't happen to a better
guy honestly I'm not going to play the
sound on this just
watch here's Tommy here's Tommy two
branches walking out of the airplane
here he's got his bag there oh boy he's
one of the best NFL coaches of all time
he really is oh [__] God damn it Tommy
Tumbl Ville couldn't happen to a better
guy I don't know maybe it's Petty of me
probably is I don't give a
[__] Gabe Sanchez says Tommy slipper
slipper bille
oh [__] them [__] them speaking of the
presidential race and Republicans
condemning people in the presidential
race you remember how Fox News o Newsmax
Steve Bannon oh man all these right
Wingers Dy wi Charlie Kirk they [__]
love them some RFK Jr oh my God they
loved RFK Jr you know what they thought
they thought you know what if we can
just get a democrat in this race against
Joe Biden and we can get we can get
someone who kind of attracts the eye of
Maga maybe just maybe just maybe we can
really [__] up the election for for Joe
Biden they don't future prooof anything
ever like they don't think past the the
[__] bigotry that's right in front of
them they're like oh yeah this will work
great [__] RFK Jr his name is Kennedy
he claims to be a Democrat and he's an
anti Banker this will really show
him this will really show him they're
terrified they're [__] terrified
because RFK Jr believed their [__]
and his own [__] this is what
happens when you get delusional
[__] running for president of
the United
States they start to believe their own
[__] like Donald Trump believes his
own
[__] right their
delusions is bliss ignorance is bliss
and I love
it what happened with RFK Jr when they
were out there pushing him as an
alternative to Joe Biden to get
Democrats to to somehow abandon Biden or
some [__] I don't know what the [__]
they thought I don't know why they
thought the superdelegates in the party
would vote for RFK Jr over Joe Biden the
incumbent president in the United States
you people are dumb as dog [__] I told
you this a long time ago and I've been
telling you this these people who act
like there's going to be some sort of
[__] primary challenge to Joe Biden
don't understand the Democratic primary
they don't get it they don't have the
facts about them to know that there's
not going to be a challenge that can be
mounted against Joe bid
with the superdelegates that are inside
the Democratic primary you dumb
[__] and anyone saying it TT or
any right-wing Network saying that [__]
is either they don't [__] know
they're ignorant and stupid or they do
know and they're lying and I believe
that's what they were doing was lying
with RFK Jr they really thought that RFK
Jr oh man this is Democrats are going to
love him because his name is
Kennedy [__] out of here with this
nonsense but now they're terrified oh my
God because they convinced the right
wing that RFK was great because he's a
nutcase they're like oh boy you want
some nutty [__] ah we'll give you some
nutty [__] and there ain't nothing more
that maanga in the right loves than
[__] Nutty Squirrel turds and godamn
is RFK Jr nuttier than a goddamn
squirrel turd frankly they're probably a
little [__] jealous of how nutty RFK
Jr is but they're terrified now that
he's got some ground with and Trump
supporters and boy they're trying to do
everything they can to stop that listen
to Shan Hannity here with RFK
Jr I mean by the way I'm I'm giving you
comments that you made in 2016 17 19 uh
endorsements we know the years Gore
Kerry Obama Hillary Bernie Sanders
they're all recent quotes the NRA quote
you made about calling them a terror
group was 2018 so these are these are
recent positions you've had that I'm I'm
not sure why the Democratic party
wouldn't allow you to compete do you
want
to do you want to uh talk about my
position Sean or you want to read
talking points from the Trump campaign
well excuse me these are not talking
points these are called Hannity points I
do my own
[Laughter]
research oh baby oh baby did you hear
what the [__] just happened there did
you hear what just [__] happened oh
man RFK JR says from the Trump campaign
remember how RFK Jr is supposed to be
running against Joe Biden remember that
[__] RFK knew he was never running
against Biden you dumb
[__] you people are some
ignorant sons of [__] if you believe
RFK Jr was going to somehow unseat Joe
Biden or Maryann Williamson or anyone
else sink hunger or [__] any tyt
[__] that they pump into your brain
they're full of [__] they're [__]
full of [__] [__] they're lying to
you tyt is lying to you anyone who says
that someone can challenge Joe Biden if
MSNBC is saying it CNN Fox News Newsmax
O N I don't give a [__] who it is if
they say that someone can challenge an
incumbent
president in a primary for their second
term with the super delegates will back
the president of the United States you
don't know how it works or you're
lying one of the other one of the other
you are [__] lying or you're dumb
you're dumb stupid and need to get some
[__] facts straight you just don't
know what the [__] you're talking about
but tyt was lying to people MSNBC when
people go on him machine like well Joe
bad he's he's old and people want to
different choice and I believe that Joe
Biden should should debate someone and I
really believe that he will debate
someone
Maryanne Williamson get the [__] out of
here with this
nonsense it's
trash it's trash they're just saying
that to [__] get yall [__] B out
of
shape and I oh my God Tony's right oh
son of a [__] he can tell the future no
it's not that I can tell the [__]
future I mean it seems like it but I
just see it for what it is what do you
want from me I just look at the [__]
facts and I know that it's true just
like this Jim Jordan thing folks right
now as it stands right now here today on
this show I'm telling you Jim I don't
report sex crimes Jordan is going to be
the next Speaker of the House it may
take a while for him to be but he is
going to be as long as Trump endorses
him as As Long As Trump endorses him he
will be the speaker of the house
period
period end of
sentence oh oh you don't believe me okay
well all right all right you don't
believe me let's listen to this guy see
what he has to say about Trump this is
why I'm not a trump fan we need leaders
who are honest ethical moral people who
can lead us and we need to demand that
as citizens of our leaders wait wait
wasn't this guy the speaker of the house
at one point wasn't he the speaker of
the house huh it it's almost it's almost
like it's almost like this guy thought
at one point that he could [__] use
Trump as a tool as a means to his end
you know what I mean and then and then
when he crossed Trump and he wasn't able
to give Trump what he wanted it's almost
like this guy had to leave
Congress in
disgrace because Trump didn't want him
there
anymore seems kind of weird seems kind
of
weird I don't know maybe and we have a
supply problem and a demand problem in
our politics today this guy always
always trying to act like he's some kind
of economic wonk you notice that always
always on [__] CNBC always on the
goddamn stock channels the stock TV
channels stock excuse me stock market TV
channels always talking H supply and
demand
bit dude you quit your [__]
job you quit your [__] job what are
you talking about supply and
demand I think we got to hit it from
both sides from the demand side as
people supply side as as leaders
leadership you have no leaders that's
the issue you only have one leader
that's what I keep trying to tell you
you dumb son of a [__] listen to me
Paul Ryan the way that Ronda santz
should have listened to me maybe you
should listen to me too you should
[__] listen
to you only have one [__] leader you
stupid [__] one one leader is what you
have you have authoritarianism the
Republican Party Paul Ryan that is why
you were [__]
flailing that is why we have to protect
our democracy from you
authoritarians not supply and demand and
some dumb [__] analogy about the
economy with why your party
sucks your party sucks because you're a
bunch of [__]
Nazis that's why sorry that's just how
it is I know you didn't want it to be
that way but it is that way and I know a
lot of [__] I know I know a lot of
liberals want to be like Tony why are
you attacking Paul Ryan he's speaking
out against Trump what the [__] are you
talking about it's the same reason why I
speak out against Liz Cheney let me show
you another clip here's [__] Liz
Cheney uh let me find it I [__] had
it earlier it's the reason why I speak
out against her because it's all bunch
of Bluster and [__] it's [__]
it's [__]
[__] all of it listen to this listen
to this [__] idiot here you go oh and
you're going to be mad at me cuz I'm
calling Liz Jan she's a hero Tony she
was on January 6 select committee listen
I believe Donald Trump himself and what
he did to try to over return the
election in 2020 to try to seize power
on January 6 y that fundamental
structure of our constitutional republic
and oh oh it it it oh okay so why did it
take you so [__] long to get to the
house floor it took Liz Cheney from from
the November election in 2020 till she
got on the house floor and said that
Donald Trump [__] lost it took 190
days
days why did it take her so long
why why did it take her so [__] long
go do the [__] math from the the the
day of the election until Liz Cheney
came to the house War she was leadership
she was third in the house in
leadership 190 days and the moment that
she did that she was out on her
ass I wonder what it could be that Paul
Ryan never spoke out against Trump until
he wasn't a congressman I wonder what it
could be that Liz Cheney waited 190 days
and now she's not a congresswoman I
wonder I wonder what the [__] it could
be about the Republican
party I wonder what it could be about
the party of the cult I wonder what the
[__] it could be huh what could it be
apparently we have some news coming in
about the speaker of the house let me
take a look at it here oh my god oh baby
oh baby the Republicans are going
against Donald Trump this is not going
to go well folks this is not going to go
well it's being reported that Steve
scales is being nominated for speaker of
the house now again they're doing this
behind closed doors oh that's not the
one I
want hang on a second I'm going to show
you this news Steve scalise is being
nominated as Speaker of the House here
we go now I got I got to tell you that
that it is possible that Donald Trump
endorses Steve scales because Steve
scales in his own words he's the David
Duke without the KKK baggage right okay
here it is b b news has it here breaking
Republicans nominee Steve
scalise uh uh KKK of Louisiana excuse me
Republican of Louisiana for house
speaker now apparently this is in their
closed door
meeting right now here here's the thing
the reason why the reason why that um
they did a closed door meeting is
because they didn't want Trump to be
involved in this [__] okay um here is
here is here's Scott McFarland let's
show this here H just to just to give
you confirmation of this news um of
Steve scales being
nominated for speaker of the house here
we go here's Scott McFarland Applause
can be heard and House GOP speaker
nomination vote meeting representative
darl I emerges and says representative
St kis won the
vote so they did it behind closed doors
but that doesn't mean [__] they still
got to go to the house floor they still
have to go to the house floor and they
need 217 this time because of how
Democrat how the house is made
up but if you believe if you believe
that Steve scal somehow is anything
better than Jim I don't report sex
crimes Jordan so that's your choices
that's the Republican's choices right
now is the guy who looks away when when
his students are being molested by his
by his his his coaching staff in Iowa
State or the guy who who Pals around
with the KKK Grand
Dragon David Duke and he claims to be
the David Duke without the KKK
baggage that's their that's their
choices
here and apparently apparently they
chose
so far so far they
chose the KKK Grand
[Laughter]
Dragon oh my
god oh [__] there's over 200 there's
over 200 Republicans in the house over
200 and really honestly you don't have
to actually choose a House member to be
the speaker I don't know if you know
that you don't actually have
to you don't actually have to [__]
pick a house or a member of the House to
be the speaker so that that leaves
thousands thousands of
Republicans that they could
choose and they're cheering yeah woohoo
we got the KKK as our nominee for
Speaker of the House W buddy oh man
that's [__] fantastic they're excited
about
it oh my
God baby
they just never disappoint do they and
and and you're always like why why does
Tony get excited about this [__] news
this is not [__] news folks this is good
news this is good news uh when you talk
about actually exposing these
[__] for who they are that's
the only option we
got that is the only option that we have
it is it is very crucial to understand
the reason why Democrats and AEM Jeff
did not pal with Kevin McCarthy to save
his ass is because there is no saving
them there's no saving them you're not
going to save the Republican party that
[__] party is dead they cannot govern
they do not want to govern they're dead
we are dragging around a dead body in
this country with the Republican
party and their choices were J Jim I
don't report sex Grimes Jordan are Steve
David Duke without the hood scalise that
was their
choices that was their [__] choices
oh someone's saying that um did Donald
Trump endorse Steve SC no [__] way no
[__] way did that happen someone's
telling me to check true social to see
what Donald Trump has to say no that's
not what I want to do godd damn it it's
want me to update true social I don't
want to update that
[__] did he endorse Steve scales
no no it doesn't look like it did
he did
he he endorsed Carrie Lake as senator of
the for Senator the senator race in
Arizona guess he's going to be the
nominee
for oh my God oh my God these [__]
people are wild it's wild stuff it's
wild stuff I don't think he did I'm
looking at it here and I'm trying to
determine this but it doesn't look like
he
did but anyways the House Republicans
are really excited about having um the
David Duke without the baggage as their
house Speaker that's pretty cool right
that's pretty cool I can't wait for that
I mean I don't know if you if you um are
part of the meme Army out there but if
you're part of the meme Army let it
start throw the meme Rockets everywhere
now let's go to let's see if we can find
some some more news on this uh this vote
see if we can get the the video of Daryl
Isa that's really what I want is the
video of Daryl Isa coming out and saying
this [__] um no that's not the video
that's not the video let's see if we can
find um Daryl Isa in the meantime while
I'm looking for that uh let's go to uh
back to this clip of Liz jany I really
want to show you this clip I really want
to show you the the remainder of this
and the hilarity of what she's saying
here because if she truly believed this
why the [__] didn't she get to the floor
of the house right if she truly believe
this what she's saying in this clip if
she truly believe this why in the [__]
didn't she tell us this listen did to
try to overturn the election in 2020 to
try to seize power um threatened that
fundamental structure uh of our
constitutional republic and and I think
it's an ongoing threat one that we all
have to come together to defeat okay so
now she's on the right path right she's
on the right path now but it took it
took a lot to get her there it took 190
days to get there and I'm not going to
stop pointing that out I know PE a lot
of people are like well you should
forgive her for that why why should I
forgive her of that why should I forgive
the person that was third in line for
leadership of the House of
Representatives in the Republican caucus
at the time why should I [__] forgive
her why shouldn't we hold her to account
too and and oh well she did the January
6 select and she finally admitted that
that Trump had lost okay so she did the
bare
minimum she did the bare minimum 190
days
later it shouldn't be that
difficult you know whatever and you guys
can hold her to a high account if you
want but it's going to be at your peril
it really is it's G to be at your peril
okay I've got some uh other Clips here
to show while I'm tracking down the
Steve scalise news um this one is by
Trey Crowder you guys know I love Trey
Crowder I'm gonna try to have cr Trey on
the show him and him and Corey Ryan
borer have a new book out uh I want I
really want to get them on the show to
talk about their book but here here's
Trey's take on RFK Jr you're going to
love this let's listen to his take on
RFK Jr while I'm looking for uh some
Steve scalise Clips well RFK Jr has
announced he's going to be an
independent next year and some people
worried that means he could play spoiler
to Joe Biden can he though and I think
you can make an argument in the reverse
if you really wanted to like here's the
trajectory of the RFK Junior campaign as
I have perceived it he came out of
nowhere sometime last year so he was
running as a Democrat and Democrats in
this country like oh we got an option
it's not Joe Biden that's great tell me
more please say he's not another Papa
well I mean he kind of is another Papa
but he's like a shirtless Papa who wears
jeans and bench presses and dug back
flips and stuff that's great he sounds
fun what's his name Kennedy Kennedy I
already know that name and as an
American I like names I already know
yeah we all do this is great so he gets
off to an early bump amongst Democrats
when they didn't know much else about
him but then they listen to him talk
right they're like all right let's hear
this guy out and Kennedy comes out there
and he's like Annie depressant called
school shootings in the chin designed Co
to spare the Jews and the base was just
like Democrats pretty quickly realized
they're like oh no this guy's crazy and
his support quickly started to wne
amongst Democrats at the same time
Republicans who were also paying
attention were like oh nice this guy's
crazy everybody go check this out listen
this is Democrat actually talking sense
y'all and by talking sense I mean being
overtly wrong about things in a
comically ludicrous fashion isn't he
great they start trotting him out there
on Fox News and CPAC and stuff because
they think he can steal votes from Joe
Biden but I'm saying I think they might
have had some unintended consequences
there because some of their people are
pretty into this guy like the only time
I ever see anyone online effusively
praising RFK Jr it's always the same
type of dude it's always like your crazy
uncle Randy who lines his trucker hat
with Tim foil and truly believes Tom
Hanks starts every day off with a baby
blood smoothie it's that guy and I'm
supposed to believe that that guy would
otherwise be a Joe Biden voter I don't
buy that and and I'm not I'm not trying
to be dismissive I know he's dangerous
his own family knows he's dangerous his
siblings put out a statement denouncing
his decision not even the ghost of their
grandpa CH Joe was in the background
like I told you we should have lomize
that kid right like it's bad and we got
to keep that in mind on the left we got
to stay motivated and we got to get the
job done we do I'm just saying I think
if after months of the rightwing
propping this dude up to their Legions
of angry whites because they think he
can be a spoiler for Biden if after all
that he instead siphons votes away from
Trump and it ends up that the
Republicans have played a Uno reverse
card on them
that would be pretty
hilarious so there's Trey Crowder I
found a clip here of Steve scales going
into this conference uh excuse me Jim
Jordan Jim I don't report sex crimes ah
[__] sorry I'm I'm I'm I'm dealing with
some computer issues here but we're
gonna get through it we're gonna get
through it hang on just bear with me
we're gonna get through this stuff now
this is what happens when you know it's
just you running the show that's right
it's just me running the show I don't
have a a big team team here behind me
doing this you can you can do commentary
and you can do political commentary and
stuff without having to uh need huge
huge amounts of teams because I got you
folks I got you you're right here we got
the mods in the chat handle in the chat
we got people over on Discord handling
the Discord we got people doing all
kinds of stuff in the background but I'm
running the show here okay here is
here's um clip of Jim I don't report sex
crimes Jordan being asked about Steve S
let's
listen Jordan will you endorse Steve
scales if he wins the votes today I
support anyone who can get 217 votes we
got to come together oh he'll support
anyone anyone anyone who can get 2117
votes he doesn't give a
[__] this is where they're at okay so
let me give you a sense of why why they
want to get a speaker as fast as
possible last week they didn't now now
they're scrambling to get a speaker
because if they don't get a speaker the
Democrats are going to keep pounding him
on the fact that hey what are you going
to do about Israel hey what are you
going to do about Israel hey what are
you going to do about Israel hey what
are you going to do about Israel right
our Ally and and Republicans have to
answer for this and if they can't get
their [__] together and govern they're
gonna prove to their own base that they
can't um govern because they can't they
can't now again I still say because
here's the fact just because they went
and picked Steve scales in this meeting
does not mean that Steve scales will be
the speaker they still have to go to the
house floor that is not that is not a
Surefire bet that they will get 217 on
the house floor now again this is why
they did the secret meeting and they
picked the speaker in the secret meeting
is because they didn't want to do it out
in the open and the reason why they
didn't want to do it out in the open is
because Donald Trump would sit and watch
it on TV and be making phone calls and
texting these [__] and telling
them what to do if they were doing it
out in the
open so they were trying to make sure
that the cult leader doesn't interfere
in their speaker their speaker election
but even so out of this [__] private
meeting that no one else is supposed to
go into they wouldn't even let them take
cell phones in again it wasn't they
didn't want them to take cell phones in
to record the meeting they didn't want
them to take electronic devices in this
meeting because they didn't want Donald
Trump texting members to do his
bidding you can doubt me all you want
you can doubt me all you [__] want
Steve scal is nominated for this house
Republican speaker because they went
against Donald Trump here that's why
they had the private meeting but it
still doesn't guarantee that Steve
scales is going to be the speaker they
have to have the house floor vote and
when they do the vote on the house floor
Donald Trump will have the ability to
interfere and it is almost guaranteed
that he will
interfere because Steve scales won't
exactly do Donald Trump's bidding
because the Republic Republicans are now
going to have to try to keep the
government open and what what what what
do we got 30 some more days until the
government shuts down again is that what
we got like 30 some more days they got
to keep the [__] government open they
can't keep the government open they
can't keep gaslighting people that
they're supporting
Israel and you if you think that that
the Republicans are going to be able to
control the eight manga idiots that
Donald Trump controls on the house floor
to torch a vote well just hide and watch
we'll see what
happens because the Republicans what
they want to have happen is the
illusion the illusion that they are
together that they're not in disarray
that is why they had the closed door
meeting to make sure that they try to
get someone that they can win with one
vote on one ballot because they know
they cannot have multiple ballot on the
floor of the house it'll embarrass
them
well embarrass them let's go to um let's
see what is happening live
here I'm doing this all you
know blind here because when I do the
show sometimes I can't see all the news
all at once and let's see are
we no it doesn't look like it doesn't
look like we're on the
uh bir has made statements um Tom Cole
has made statements of Oklahoma or uh
yeah of Oklahoma and Byron Donald's oh
has made statements as well it looks
like maybe we'll go track those down as
well um to see what is going on there
again we're going to keep you a breast
of this as far as what the news is going
to be um oh my God Don Hall says I
nominate Tony Michaels as Speaker of the
House no no I I I get your sentiment
there Don but the problem is is that we
shouldn't have people who clown in
Congress let alone Speaker of the House
my job is to clown that's the whole
point my job is to clown these
[__] because they're [__]
clowns they're the caucus of clowns
they're the clown caucus as I put on the
thumbnail today and as long as they
continue the circus in Congress which is
what we don't need we need we need
level-headed serious people in Congress
the last thing they would need is a
clown like me a clown like me in
Congress but I appreciate the sentiment
I appreciate it
H let's see um you know what let's let's
go back to some other news we'll come
back to the speaker stuff as it
unfolds
um let's see what we got here I'm just
trying to see if we can get some
VI some VI so you can see the inside of
this now what's happening other than me
just describing news sometimes it's
better to have a visual aid you know
what I mean
um
okay let's um again the the choices for
speaker of the house here was Jim I
don't report sex crimes Jordan and Steve
scales in his own words I'm the David
Duke without the KKK baggage um that's
their choices and they chose the grand
wizard of the
KKK um
wow so we'll see we'll see if if we'll
see if they select the KKK Dr Grand
Wizard or they select Jim Jordan who is
the uh apparently endorsed candidate for
Donald Trump it is likely when they go
to a house floor vote that it will be
both of them that are nominated possibly
someone else okay so let's go back to um
to the other news I want to show you I
it's we're at the bottom of the hour and
Gabe Sanchez is gonna be joining us he's
doing his live show today he had his
power off yesterday but his power is
back and going uh so he's going to be
joining us and having a show show what
was that live right after this uh show
so if you're on YouTube or twitch don't
go anywhere you're going to want to stay
here so you can watch what was that live
with Gabe Sanchez um here on YouTube and
twitch uh let's see oh I want to show
you this little piece of the news
speaking of Grandpa poopy pants
endorsing Jim I don't report sex crimes
Jordan apparently he doesn't know how to
pronounce Hamas which is not surprising
but let's listen to this demented fool
heard about today the humus the what
terrorist
Invasion I mean when the is he saying
hummus the hummus terrorist is that what
he's saying what's backing up let's see
what did he say let's listen heard about
today the humus humus humus terrorist
Invasion huh I mean when you think about
and what are you are you serious now I
thought Joe B Joe Biden was a little I
thought he was the one that was kind of
losing his mind let's listen again I
swear he says humus he didn't let's
let's listen about today the
hummus hummus terrorist okay I guess
there's hummus terrorist there maybe
nacho cheese terrorist I don't know
maybe there's Vita terrorist too I [__]
I don't know I have no idea I don't know
who they're committing Terror against or
in four you know I have no idea I don't
know what a hummus terrorist
is holy [__] are you [__] kidding me
this [__] dude oh
wow apparently the Israelis were
attacked by
hummus oh boy okay so I want to show you
the speaking of danger of
terrorist uh you know I've been talking
about this mayor's race in in Franklin
Tennessee I'm sure these Nazis are
eventually going to find out that I'm
yelling and screaming about this and
they're going to start getting pissed
off at me uh but we'll see we'll see if
they will or not I hope they do uh that
is a good enemy for me to have now uh
this is let this is a thread here from
Phil Williams uh we know Phil Williams
is the is the investigative reporter for
nc5 Channel 5 News there in Nashville
who has been staying on top of the story
but he post this thread of the rest of
these oldermen um
um condemning the oldermen because
Hansen is a actually holds a seat on the
board of alderman there in Franklin
she's trying to become the mayor but she
actually holds this clown this Nazi
clown holds a
seat uh
in in Franklin but let's listen to some
of her olderman colleagues here that are
also elected
officials um it's embarrassing to end up
on HBO to end up on MSNBC and not for
the good stuff that's that's the
embarrassing part I you know I I I get
her sentiment here right right and I
know she's trying to speak out against
this idiot but really that's the most
embarrassing thing is that you ended up
on TV because one of your aldermans is a
Nazi like the most embarrassing thing is
that you guys have an Alderman who is a
[__] Nazi that should be the most
embarrassing thing about it all like
really okay let's keep going it's all
triced down to one
source so I think that I I know that
when we are able to provide a legal
censure motion I will definitely um
support that because I think we need to
make a stand um we fight for our
citizens every day in this role we can't
all right there you go so now again
Hansen is running against a republican
an incumbent Republican for mayor okay
so understand that so like this is
Republican Ville USA this is not like
this not like Hansen's trying to fight
against you know some liard democrat or
some [__] she's running against a
republican
uh oh here here you go this is good too
here's another this this this Alderman
name is Jason Potts the last one is
Brandy uh blaton BL blon uh was the last
one here is Jason Potts here's this
Alderman's statement to um to Hansen
what's been going on here lately has to
stop and it has to stop now the
environment that all of us has had have
had to endure recently is truly a
concerning State of
Affairs fear and intimidation and in and
hatred have no home in
Franklin well I mean they do they do I I
I don't know I don't know if he knows
this but uh someone that's trying to run
for mayor there who has support in the
community from Nazis
um they hate people see they they want
to they want to get rid of lgbtq
people
in in Franklin so there is hate in
Franklin it's just you guys are
embarrassed because it's now being
pointed out and it's weird that you're
only embarrassed now that it's being
pointed out but you know go
on silence and inaction is a choice with
severe consequences oh oh so now that
it's being pointed out by Phil
Williams and it's not like this this
idiot hasn't been anti-lgbt this Hansen
has been
anti-lgbt and calling uh for people not
to be able to participate in the
community because they are
lgbtq you were silent then weren't you
maybe not but you know I'm just I'm just
trying to point out some [__] here that
can forever change the character of
Franklin which is deeply rooted in in
love and concern for our families and
neighbors I hope that is true I honestly
hope this is true I hope that is true
for Franklin what this Alderman Jason
John John Jason no Jason pot sorry Jason
pots I want to get my fact straight here
now all these videos are from uh Phil
Williams and they're in the thread that
I retweeted um here is Beverly Burger
I'm not making that up it's Beverly
Burger here's her statement uh at the
Alderman's meeting against Hansen if if
you're looking here this is Hansen right
here right there she's sitting right
there and I'm going to get to her
statement here in a minute and it's
[__] disgusting because she's a
disgusting [__] Nazi and that's why
it's disgusting but we'll get to that
but let's let's hear from uh Alderman
berer here answer Alderman
Hansen I think the question our board
and our community want answered from you
is it your mission to divide our city
because you're doing a bang up job of it
right now dividing our
community I've had numerous people write
me and tell me that we could avoided all
of this Division if only the mayor had
voted for the Franklin Pride application
approval okay so that's that's where a
lot of this is the the the Lynch pen of
this is happening they were trying to
have a pride event in Franklin and they
were looking for um a a permit to have
in a public space right and they'd had
it before and you know they went back
and forth and the Alderman and the mayor
and they they voted rather to to have it
or not to have it which is [__]
despicable in the first place that they
wouldn't allow this peaceful event that
has been peaceful in the past there
hasn't been any kind of violence or
anything or any of that [__] they just
they just [__] hate these people who
are gonna use this public space for
their their event that's what they
that's what it's all about that's why
the Nazis are getting involved
and again if if you're wondering why
I equate manga and Hamas this is where
it starts this is how it starts it
starts in a small community in a place
like Franklin Tennessee and it Bubbles
and it Bubbles and it Bubbles and it
Bubbles and they gain ground and they
gain ground and they gain ground and
they make this illegal they make it to
where you can't wear a dress in
Tennessee illegal which they've tried to
do they tried to make drag illegal in
Tennessee they try to paint every single
person who is the lgbtq community or an
ally somehow some kind of pedophile or
some [__] and and and and and which
Stokes violence and that's what the
Nazis want that's what they want that's
what they continue to do even though
none of it's the [__] truth it's all
propaganda and you get mad at me when I
call manga because I don't know if you
know this but Hanson is MAA through and
through and through and through if
you're not aware of who she [__]
voted for you're an idiot but here's
let's listen to a little more of
alderman bur's here
statement don't I wish that it was that
simple that cut and dry that conclusion
is not supported by all the facts as we
know it now mayor and i r on opposite
ends of that vote but I certainly
understand your vote a lot better Mr
Mayor and I do respect it and we will
work to make sure our community is
secure with good solid Community Values
people will have their freedoms intact
but they will be Towing the mark of
Community decency oh so she's not she's
not for the Nazis she's just kind of
like Nazi adjacent do you you see that
there she wasn't for the vote to make
sure to have this public space available
for people to have a a pride event she
disagreed with that but and she she now
now that she knows who is behind that
effort to make sure that they didn't
have that event is Nazis literal Nazis
and that Hansen was behind the Nazis
helping do that [__] that now she's now
she's not oh she's ah but do you see do
you see how it works do you see why I
call them out on the rug is because when
they are pressed even the people who are
with the Nazis even the people who agree
with the policy of the Nazis when they
are called Nazis when they are called
out on the rug when people point at them
and say well I mean Hansen's you know
ping up with the Nazis but by God you
sound like one of too they're like no no
no no no no no no no no no not me not me
I'm definitely not that I'm definitely
not that do you see how they
switch and they
run that's the whole point it's the
whole point well let's keep
going this division started about six
months after you were Seated on the
board I chose to ignore it not wanting
to think ill of you because I liked you
oh really you were a fellow board member
and we got involved you got involved you
took your role seriously you did great
work on sister cities Etc you also went
to bat and Champion some very important
issues that were not just quite right
like the resoning of a church property
and the overregulation of gathering for
people for prayer on the
Square I was on the same page as you and
so were all these other oldermen but
soon it seemed there was something under
every Rock oh oh oh I believed in all
your Nazi beliefs oh I believed all that
I am down with the Nazis I just don't
want people to think that I am
one you see that you see that you see
how that works you see how that works
H so when I when I call Rhonda santz a
Nazi for him not condemning the actual
neo-nazis that show up on an overpass in
Florida to how Hitler in his name do you
see you see why that's
important just because this one even in
her re her
rebuke to Hansen here she still admits
that she loves her Nazi views it's kind
of gross isn't it the Covenant murders
the juneth sponsorship issues then the
BNA letter then the middle a development
Alderman Peterson voted against it and
yet she has not thrown people under the
bus and used it as a political tool for
her
campaign that's called
Integrity oh boy they're really mad that
the the that the nation's paying
attention to their little community and
how they are they have they're they're
Nazi as someone said in the chat
nazish they're nazish like adjacent but
again if there's a Nazi sitting at a
table eating
dinner and your ass goes over there and
Chucks up with them now pads around with
them and doesn't push back or tell them
there a Nazi or put them in their place
and there's 10 people yucking it up at
that table with that Nazi there's 11
Nazis at the table it's how it works
here's here's another Alderman one of
those sources is the admitted Nazi
leader himself Brad Lewis now this guy's
going to do a little bit better job I'll
admit I've watched this clip here uh
through the through the entirety of it
his name is Matt Brown and he does a
much better job at pushing back with the
facts and getting to the heart of it but
listen Mr Lewis stated unequivocably
that Alderman Hansen wanted their help
and invited them to engage this isn't
the media or the left making this claim
this truth is coming directly from the
source moreover Alderman Hansen shared a
discussion that contained a particularly
alarming phrase in her social media the
phrase there is is no political solution
appeared in a chat with a Tennessee
active Club a chat that apparently
Alderman Hansen was included in this
phrase isn't merely a statement it's a
dangerous rhetoric associated with
extremist ideologies it is an
acceleration of the white power movement
make no mistake it is a call for
violence Alman Hansen may not have
written that phrase but her sharing it
publicly specifically including that
screenshot is prizing and advancing that
call for
violence to further underscore the
gravity of the situation being created
here at a meet and greet this weekend a
resident questioned Alderman Hansen
about threats that had been made on this
resident's Life by the Tennessee active
Club Alderman Hansen requested that the
resident show her a screenshot of the
threat and proceeded to take a picture
of her phone
screen that image which only lives on
the phone of the Hansen campaign ended
up being shared later by the Tennessee
active club with a renewed threat to
silence this
resident as unbelievable as this is it
is a fact that A Renewed threat was
Amplified by the club using information
sourced directly from Alman Hansen
campaign there is no other way for them
to have received that exact
image veiled or not so veiled threats to
end someone's life simply because they
are engaging in the Civic process
engaged in our local election it is not
Al manic it is not mayoral and it is
certainly not Christian oh boy he really
digs in there does he he did a better
job than the rest of them I
think calling her not a Christian at the
end he talking about the cherry on top
someone says here crystal says hang on
crystal I'm gonna bring your comment up
here crystal says Tennessee holler made
us aware of this [__] yes Tennessee
holler is one that has been reporting on
this but Phil Williams is the one that
I'm showing his videos here Phil
Williams and it his handle is nc5 pH
Phil Williams on Twitter if you go on
Twitter but you can probably find him
other places but he's been reporting on
this he's the one on the ground
reporting on this um Tennessee holler
has been amplifying has been amplifying
um the the reports Phil Williams reports
I have been John Oliver has been and I'm
going to continue doing this um and I
want to thank the Tennessee holler
because I showed a clip of them the
other day I think they pointed out the
the John Oliver clip to me um but we got
to keep on top of this because this is
this is an important story inside of our
country I know it feels like it's some
little ply ass story in a Ply ass
Community but there this is a reflection
of what communities around the countries
could be enduring if we don't stay
vigilant but here is Hansen here uh with
her statement listen to this
[Music]
[__] and of course the citizens of
Franklin don't deserve this but this is
the old adage of you reap what you sow
you've planted seeds for years and years
against our citizens and they're coming
to harvest this is not Nazi propaganda I
don't know if you're listening to what
the [__] she's saying keep going keep
going grab your own hon you're only
proving that you're Nazi keep going you
dumbass this is what the citizens of
Franklin are getting because of bad
decisions because of attacks on a church
because attacks on a Latino church
because attacks on a worship minister in
our square and ultimately a man who was
arrested in our parks for wearing a
Jesus shirt and expressing his
Christianity and his love for Christ
those things are called spiritual
repercussions and they do come back to
you and it's easy to shift all the blame
I just happened to arrive at a time
where everything was starting to crumble
oh man she really leans into the whole
Hitler thing she should grow her a
[__] little mustache shouldn't she I
think she should oh my God I think she
should grow her a little [__]
mustache
here she's good at this TI stuff she
really is no wonder she gets the proud
boy Nazi to be her to be her Defender
and her supporter they really taught her
well and that's where we are today is in
a community who's been built on a
massive PR machine but a community who
is so focused on the past it's hard to
deal with the present a community who's
left many voices out to dry with a set
of rules for different tiers of
individuals in our community we've had
this a and packed with hundreds of
peoples whose voices were never heard
because our leadership fell on deaf ears
of their cries but I have nothing else
to say other
than this is exactly the seeds that you
sewed in your Harvest is now here and
they were here because they are an
anti-antifa group
and wait a second wait a second what she
say what she say go back go back go back
listen to this listen what she calls
them listen to what she calls the Nazis
here listen to what she calls the Nazis
listen exactly the seeds that you sewed
in your Harvest is now here and they
were here because they are an
anti-antifa
group they're an anti- antifa
group you mean Nazis right you know what
you know what antifa means it means anti
fascist so if they're anti antifa
they're
anti-nazi okay they're against Nazis
like you you [__] trunt what the [__]
what is anti antifa
group oh my God these [__] people oh
these [__] people will do anything
anything to be a Nazi just not call
thems a Nazi this is [__] wonderful
keep going you stupid ass and the dark
web is showing massive antifa activity
with a state antifa leader that lives
about 15 minutes from Franklin
Tennessee oh so it's the antifa guy the
guy who's against Nazis that lives 15
minutes that that that she's terrified
of and that's why they came out and I
don't denounce any of my clients I have
oh you hear that back that up a second
wait a second you thought she was GNA
denounce the anti-antifa Nazis let's
listen 15 minutes from Franklin
Tennessee here it is and that's why they
came out yeah and I don't denounce any
of my clients I have a black clients she
doesn't oh she can't denounce any of her
clients that's what we're calling Nazis
now the anti- antifa
clients the anti- antifa clients now
she's gonna do the whole black friend
thing here I'm not [__] you she
really leans into stupidity here she's
going to do it watch client a lesbian I
have a black client a lesbian client a
Muslim client I have BR Lewis as a
client I'm a realtor I'm not going to
denounce you're not you're not gonna be
a realtor much longer lady you're just
not I don't and Franklin you're probably
not you may you may you may be able to
go to some other state and be um be a a
realtor in some other state but I doubt
in Franklin you're going to be a realtor
much longer I I don't believe you're
going to be able to attract many clients
now that you're being exposed for who
you truly are and your own words are
really hurting you but keep going keep
going with the words and I don't
denounce any of my clients I have a
black client a lesbian client a Muslim
client I have Brad Lewis as a client I'm
a realtor I'm not going to denounce
anybody their right to be whatever it is
that they want to be whether I agree
with what they do in their personal life
or not so when they wanted to come
because they were concerned about what
they saw on the dark web I said please
do not make a scene if you're oh well
come and don't make a Nazi scene just
make it anti- antifa yeah okay well keep
going you dumbass going to come if they
want to support you in your reelection
if they want to support me that is their
right and we don't discriminate in this
community against
anyone I mean anyone besides the people
that she hates that's what she likes to
discriminate against oh boy we have
someone here
uh oh uh oh we got someone here
someone's in the green room let's is
there music going to be playing is
there is with the left name s
cheese who are you talking about oh what
that's that's a personal attack oh I see
the who is who's here who's here on the
Tony Michaels podcast it is Gabe Sanchez
who
is are you are you just playing where
are you playing that's a
secret
secret Gabe Sanchez everyone hey hey hey
Gabe Sanchez there he is Gabe Sanchez
what's happening what's happening what's
happening good we were just we were just
knocking on some Nazis you know typical
typical day here at the Tony Michaels
podcast making sure that
all the Nazis yeah have you heard this
story in in in Franklin Tennessee this
is a crazy story no am I surprised that
it's in Franklin Tennessee no well you
you really honestly um you should put
this on your what was that list it's a
hell of a story it's a it's a great it's
a great drama in a fascist who believes
Nazis she calls them her anti antifa
clients that's what she calls the Nazis
she's like wait is this the yeah that's
it mhm I think I know which one where
the Nazis were protecting her she's
running for mayor yeah it's that story
but it's getting much juicier because
all the aldermen in in the in the
community that were kind of with her
were kind of friends with her pound
around with her now that now that she's
got the Nazis on their side they're like
maybe not so much maybe uh not so much
right they did not see that coming where
she would actually invite them and she'd
be you know walking arm in- arm with
them and then threatening voters lives
on online on telegram which is you know
that's pretty cool right they did or she
did I mean at well at a campaign event
that that Hansen held uh a supporter or
a voter who who um is supporter of the
other candidate I guess went to ask
Hansen questions that they've been
threatened by her Nazi friends excuse me
her anti antifa clients her aunti antifa
clients whatever the [__] that means um
they were threatened online and they
showed her the screenshot on Facebook I
believe it was or on telegram whichever
platform it was and uh Hansen's campaign
staff took a picture of the screen not a
screenshot took a picture of the screen
well just hours later it ended up on
telegram under these Nazis accounts that
actual picture of her screen like it's
the picture of her screen that this
person took it ended up on telegram with
another death threat uh to that
[Music]
voter that's it would make it hell of a
I'm just saying just I'm just saying
that's a let me let me dig you're doing
what was that live today right I'm doing
yes I'm doing what was that live today
you're doing what was that live live
today yesterday you out of power B power
they were doing work down the street and
they hit the grid and they killed it
killed it that hit the grid that sounds
that's I'm not gonna lie that sounds
fake hit the grid I mean dude this is is
there like this big box that says grid
on it there in in California I don't
know I mean it's underground someone hit
it when
Yeah just they [__] GD you know kind
of
as blocks of power uh yeah I had that
happen to me I had that happen to me
once in San Francisco I lost power
because they were doing the building an
apartment complex next to mine had burnt
down and Jesus Christ I was it's a sto
dude it's crazy it's crazy it's a crazy
story point
is uh they were they were using uh
caterpillars you know to dig up all of
the debris The Machine caterpillars not
actual not actual caterpillars we're not
there yet all right so they had a huge
caterpillar digging up and they and at
the time underneath the apartment
complex there was like a market and in
the market was where they had the grid
for the block right so they had all the
power that was there well they didn't
realize I guess or remember that when
they were going to dig up all the the
debris that there was actually a a level
of like eight to 10 feet underneath them
and so not only did one of the
caterpillars fall down into the ground
and had to get recovered by another
caterpillar but what ended up happening
was uh they dug up they just put the CL
like we're going to take up all this
like wooden stuff and then pulled the
whole electrical grid for the block so
like Alm Draft House and every business
down the block everything sh like power
just went out nobody could do anything
for the whole day until um until the
power you know the SF power came over
and had to repair everything but it was
[__] it was just like dangling dangling
in this caterpillar just
wires and did it say grid the Grid on it
said the grid the grid yeah it's do not
touch the grid the grid this is the grid
okay well good so let me ask you I know
you're gonna cover a couple stories
today and you got to get going but I
want to know are you going to cover you
got to get you got to get your boy G
Santos you got to get what the hell
coming get your boy here Georgie Porgy I
uh I filmed a what was that so I'm gonna
I'm gonna edit that today so I'll give a
little detail I'll go into the specifics
but um yeah I'm I'm gonna talk about
obviously this like House Divided type
of [__] in the GOP it looks like Steve
skes got the majority of their V well he
he got the he got the underground vote
now whether he'll get on the house floor
now my my assumption was and I'm I'm um
postulating that they did it behind
closed doors without electronic devices
so Trump couldn't interfere but that
won't be the case on the house they'll
have their electronic devices and Trump
will be able to text and call and be
able to interfere but the other story I
want to see if you're going to talk
about today before we go before we shoot
to your show is you gonna talk about
this [__] are you gonna talk about this
[__] what I'm just asking is this a
real pict the the new member of the the
Chipmunks yeah the new Alvin yeah Alvin
and the Alvin and the [__] I don't
don't know I think this is this real I
don't know I don't know if this is real
I mean you know many people are saying
it people are saying it's real there's a
photo of it so it must be real must be
it's got to be real are you gonna cover
that story no yeah I'll cover I'll cover
that [__] [__] that one I'm a
Victor hit Georgie Porgy I didn't hit
him too hard you know I I figured you
were gonna you know get in I I don't
want I don't want to show all my moves
but I gotta go go get out of here get
out of here go to your show go to do
your show everyone thanks for joining us
here on the Tony Michaels don't forget
to stick around here on YouTube and
twitch if you're on Facebook come on
YouTube or twitch and and watch I am
Gabe Sanchez just go to YouTube or
twitch and type in I am gab Sanchez or
go to I am gab sanchez. comom you'll
find it there don't forget to subscribe
here on YouTube at the Tony Michaels
podcast don't forget to follow us on
Twitch or follow us on Facebook where
you can watch us every single weekday
noon Eastern 11 Central nine Pacific two
full hours same time same place tomorrow
tomorrow don't go anywhere Gabe Sanchez
is right after this Surfs Up
[__] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast podcast in
your face commentary of current events
and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow Tony on social media at
the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] them [__]
[Music]
them Murphy's mebn head ass
speaking